Amy nürnberg our arms a research data
manager here at Columbia yes I'm new if
you're at Columbia come talk to me about
your research data I can't wait but I'm
very thankful for today's event it's
been extremely thought-provoking and I'd
like to thank everyone who has supported
it and contributed to it so thank you
very much a round of applause for those
people now to draw the day to a close
it's my pleasure to introduce Bob Chen
who's graciously stepping in for young
brazo who was not able to make it and
Bob will be providing closing remarks
and some incisive insights into today's
conversation bob is the director of at
the Center for International earth
science information network of the Earth
Institute at Columbia University and is
also a senior research scientist he also
manages the socio-economic data and
application center a data center in the
NASA Earth observing and information
system and Chen is also the former
secretary-general of the committee on
data science and technology of the
international council for science and a
current member of the NRC board on
international scientific or scientific
organizations so Bob please yeah end of
the day I actually do have some slides I
gave which of course we're done before
and and you probably don't want a long
talk and we're behind schedule so let me
just fairly quickly I think we've had a
quite a good discussion today I was
impressed also impressed that a lot of
people are still here but I did want to
reflect on where we're going and
although it's really too bad yon
couldn't make it i think one thing at
least from my perspective you may
disagree i want to bring in here is that
you know a lot of this this is a
research data symposium and we've been
talking a lot about scientists but we
actually haven't been talking a lot
about science and Peter Marie rest very
quickly in his intro said you know
values matter the planet is under
pressure
they're big problems out there and even
though I'm half a data scientists I'm
also half working scientists my Center
does all sorts of interdisciplinary
research we help monitor the progress
towards the Millennium Development Goals
and the millennium villages we're
advising governments in Africa on
adaptation to climate change I do work
integrating data on different natural
hazards and how they pose risks and two
different populations around the world
you know we're we're a I run a data
center that takes data secondary data
mostly puts it together creates global
data sets for use in modeling and
applications and so forth so there's a
purpose to the science and I'm very
supportive you know open data is key
it's key to doing things more
efficiently to doing those secondary
activities but it is also still the
means to an end and if the date is not
open but you need that data to solve a
problem you know you know I don't get
hung up in whether it's open or not I
need the data and you you do things to
do that and I think a lot of scientists
are that so so we do have to keep I
think the perspective that the goal of
science is I think as was mentioned
earlier to benefit people and and to use
the science in the best way possible and
make it the most efficient but now
reflecting on the talk I use this a lot
and it's a Creative Commons license
comic hopefully you guys all read XKCD
regularly but you know we were not
designed to sift through petabytes of
data we were not our evolution is not
you know equipping us very well
obviously to type a lot because we all
get carpal tunnel syndrome and so forth
so this this works on on that level it
also works on the level that the planet
is reaching boundaries we are
running into crises and you know there
are physical perfect storms there are
lots of potential issues related to
sustainability and and we're in the
middle of it so you know one of the
hopeful benefits of open science of this
great technology of all the things we
heard is that it will help science solve
big problems that we're all facing and
that affect all of us whether you're you
know here in New York City where
somewhere else Micah you said you were
talking about climate versus weather and
I when people usually explain climate
versus whether they're trying to explain
the difference between the first trend
which is you know the change in in the
overall climate of the earth on the
cattle are longer time scales and
weather which is you know a storm like
sandy coming and affecting a lot of
people so continuing to use a few
cartoons I'm sure you've seen this one
which is often what we see and I think
there was a hint of someone saying oh
there are too many platforms out there
we're just going to have another
standard and even though we think we're
solving the big problem and actually the
latest of XKCD which i only added to
this this morning is this one which i
thought was nice which is of course
there are standards like I guess what is
is is 0 8 21 or something is it's called
which of course everybody ignores or
almost everybody so I mean what we've
seen is a creative process of lots of
people doing lots of interesting things
with all sorts of data all different
kinds of technologies you know new
stakeholders new partnerships public and
private sector government's
experimenting and different things you
know I think one good thing is at least
this administration is thinking about
the problems it's it's issuing new
policies it's having
I h and other agencies actually
implementing and funding going further
some of you were involved in a new
international initiative called the
research data Alliance which is being
launched in Sweden in a couple of weeks
NSF is putting money into it the
Europeans the Australians are all
recognizing this is a problem and it's
an end-to-end problem it's it's it's
integrated into the whole science
research process it's not just a single
thing you can fix it's something that
requires all sorts of activity you know
new technology new workforce new
training new I'm involved with a group
that's working on legal interoperability
how do you get at some of these legal
constraints and issues working across
disciplines working across national
borders so that you know I think we've
heard a lot of today about how you know
data rights are critical that can't be
ignored the business model is critical
we need to be exploring different ways
obviously no one has the solution yet
and there's one last week's XKCD was a
little kind of a downer but anyway
really reflects that you know one of the
issues we have a data is that you know
we're all mortal we're not necessarily
going to survive our data else so that
will actually brings me to some to a one
final which is actually not it so that's
why we need to preserve our data one
little thing which comes from a paper
Bob downs and I did a few years ago and
it was inspired cuz I was at a
conference with a bunch of earth
scientists and space scientists 78 years
ago and the the space scientists in
particular were making the claim that
NASA an agency invented about 50 years
ago was going to keep data on the
history of the universe forever
how many people what's the age of the
universe you know thirteen point seven
seven billion years and these guys in
the same sentence said NASA a
fifty-year-old organization is going to
keep data forever when you know their
other definition are forever is more
than 13 billion years so this doesn't
even come close but what it was making a
point and we see this you know we've
been we're witnessing this every week or
month or two which is government is
great but it can turn off on a dime it
can be you know Congress can pass a law
or a president can do something and and
really cut it off at the knees and
they're very few institutions Treasury
was one of the longest that even have
something close to the longevity it
persists American universities they're
they're certainly European universities
that are longer live but you know at
least some of our universities are
Harvard people are they all gone anyway
to have the greatest longevity and and
it it's that you know thinking
institutionally beyond our individual
capacity is is important and I think you
know it's kind of nice having the
libraries sponsored this bringing in
this kind of community and being the
framework and working with partners like
elsevier to think about what the real
long-term knowledge preservation and
access responsibility is and how you
know that obviously has to respond to
the way society is changing and then way
the internet and people and individuals
and technology and so forth are changing
but still where's the longevity come
from right now our main experience is in
places of knowledge and and scholarship
like universities and there may be
others i mean i know not everybody wants
views academia in the same way but i
think thinking about the institutional
context of a lot of what we discussed
here is important and and things that
can succeed and be
useful you know in the short term may be
very valuable to science but on the
other hand there's also the need to have
a mechanism by which those become part
of alarm longer infrastructure that has
a you know an exit strategy as somebody
said or a transition plan or or you know
and the duty and the responsibility to
think about okay that was great when it
was great and it's past its time but we
still need some parts of that knowledge
to transfer and to migrate with us you
know beyond the retirement or the
passing or the graduation or whatever of
the individual people involved so that's
sort of one little thing I think that
kind of underpins some of the discussion
we had today and obviously there's no
solution but i think you know as a
scientist I think we have to step back
and think about how those pieces fit
together and think about the
institutional design that will make us
all well live virtually forever Thanks
alright so could you load up my slides
30 I'm just kidding thanks everyone my
name is kelechi okaeri I'm one of the
regional sales directors at how severe
and I just want to thank enclosing and
closing out the day I want to thank all
of you for showing up putting these
events together these types of programs
together it's always nerve-racking you
never know you know who's going to show
up how many people are going to show up
so one Jim Neal mentioned how this
program came together this was last
summer a lunch meeting with myself and
our CEO and Jim and you know where he
talked very passionately about dealing
with preserving scholarship beyond the
journal
and research data and how to deal with
it was one of those things so we sort of
proposed continuing a conversation in
this forum in a forum like this and I'm
very grateful to to Jim for agreeing to
host this to have the conversation and I
think it's been a fantastic day so I
want to give another round of applause
to all the presenters so in closing I
thank Jim I thank catherine Pope Rebecca
Kennison Leila if I'm forgetting anyone
so the entire Columbia crew that work
with with us elsevier and putting this
program together I really thank everyone
for making it happen the other thing I
will say is also for so everyone heard
you saw the presentation from David
marks the research data initiative is
something that also deserves here is
about if you want to collaborate with us
you're an institution I want to
collaborate with us please get in touch
with us we're very willing to work with
institutions to learn more deeply how
you're dealing with the research starter
that your researchers are producing so
please do get in touch with us if you
are interested in working with us also
in terms of future programs like this if
you like this program and you have other
ideas of other conversations that you
want to have please also talk to us
again this came about because of a lunch
meeting that we had last summer and here
we are with a fantastic program so
please also do talk to us about that the
last thing I'll mention is that we will
send evaluation forms by email so please
please do us a favor and fill out those
evaluations when you get them this will
let us know how much you enjoy the
program and also what how we can improve
future programs it will also help me
let's say gate good performance reviews
next year so so again in closing I want
to thank everyone for coming it's been a
fantastic day fantastic program they
started out raining but the rain has
stopped so thank you so much and travel
home safely